chris handed me an article right as
we're going on the air
survival mode over 68 percent of
americans had
financial setbacks in 2020 amid
the pandemic more than two-thirds of
americans experienced financial setbacks
in 2020 due to job loss declining
household income
or drawdown of emergency savings
according to a new
fidelity study job loss declining
household income
or drawdown of emergency savings okay
the report by the financial services
company also looked at how americans
plan to handle their finances
as they head into 2021 and continue to
face challenges brought on by the
pandemic well let me correct you on that
usa today it's not brought on by the
pandemic
the financial challenges are not on
brought on by the pandemic
they're brought on by the economic
shutdown because of
as they that's what the government says
okay and the government
it's brought on by your government
that's where your financial problems are
brought on by when you shut down
people's
ability to make a lie make an income
then they're going to have financial
trouble that really wouldn't be an
insight usa today
um that would be a fairly obvious
conclusion
that's cause and effect but it's not the
pandemic the pandemic didn't cause it
because people being sick with covet did
not cause the economy to collapse
these shutdowns by the government caused
the
economy to collapse in fear of
people being sick with a pandemic
and um you know lots of things to
discuss there
of the people surveyed over 38 said they
will spend the year in survival mode
now what i want to talk about chris from
this was i
get anytime i see it's a good survey
sample size is 3 000 people so it's a
it's a legitimate statistical
uh statistically significant uh i don't
know the wording
of the questions that they use to draw
their conclusions with
having studied statistics and you and i
spent a lot of time on
research uh methodology when we were
building out our company was building
out with an outside research firm
the study for millionaire right and we
want to be careful to not ask the
question in such a way that it's leading
and we don't want to say okay what's
really going on we want to get behind
what's going on so
for instance in this uh 38
say they're in survival mode
in 2021 but the unemployment rate
is six percent
so you know well i mean if you're two
household income you lost one income
right and you had bills based on double
income you could be in survival mode
and still not be unemployed one one
person but the other will not be right
so that's
possible but what i would read
between the lines into this research and
say is
that one of the biggest problems with
the economic
shutdown brought on by the government
uh in an attempt to control the pandemic
um it
is that it has affected attitudes more
than reality
depression is up no without a doubt
suicide is up
as dr dolani calls them the diseases of
despair
are up and so my attitude
my belief that things are worse than
they really are
in my house because they're i watch the
news so much
my house is actually okay but i watch
the news so much that i think things are
bad so i go into survival mode
okay i'm with you and it's not an actual
mathematic
thing oh it's a self-fulfilling prophecy
it's a it's a uh i'm freaked out
because i've watched the news so much
right
that told me that it was coming to an
end and i listened to the governor of
uh california and i listened to the
governor of new york and i said we're
all going to die
and so it's you know we're it's over we
need to stay inside and just wait on
death to come
and uh we're locked down again still
except for the people that left those
two states which is half the freaking
population there
would the last person out of california
please turn out the lights
oh my god you people are all leaving but
the uh uh
and moving here why yes leave us alone
we like tennessee um anyway
the uh uh so so the the point is not all
of that but the point is
that yes people are really hurting
yeah some are and we're here to help you
we do that
but some of it is and this is what i
want to warn our listeners about
because if you believe things are going
bad and you start taking all your
decisions based on things going bad
you're going to cause them to go bad
what you said
self-fulfilling prophecy right no no
that's absolutely true
and in looking at this it said 68 of
people had setbacks
23 percent lost a job or household
income 20 percent
had an unexpected non-health emergency
18 percent had to provide unexpected
financial aid to family or friends
and then sixteen percent had a health
emergency in their family i mean what
was the unexpected health
uh down here of the first page uh 20
had an unexpected non-health emergency
non-health emergency so that's
called an emergency that's one in five
right well okay the number we've quoted
for a thousand years around here and it
stayed true was that 78
of americans in any given uh
peri in any given year right will have a
an emergency yeah and 20 that's about
right then
20 would normally do that without covid
without it
a non-health emergency about 20 of
people have a non-health emergency no 78
days it was in a five-year period of
time wasn't it yes that status
that old stat we used to quote there's
an old money magazine stuff
yeah it's old but i mean it's still
accurate because life hasn't changed
that much plus or minus pandemic crap
but
um yeah so 78 of americans
have a a an emergency in any given
oh no that's in a given decade that's
what so it would be about 20 it would be
yeah that's not that's not far off okay
so what i'm trying to figure out here is
this
so if they surveyed me and they said did
you have a financial setback this year
i could easily say yes yes we lost the
entire
segment of revenue at ramsey solutions
of live events not the entire but we
lost 90
of it however other areas of the
business
are up to the point that our overall
revenues are up right year over year
not down but i did receive setbacks yeah
so it depends on my attitude
situation is how i would answer that so
i could go oh god things are bad and
eeyore is my spirit animal and so it's
all bad and it's just not going anywhere
and
i've had setbacks this year and we have
had setbacks right and it's been very
freaking stressful and it's been hard
and it's been really hard for some of
you out there i know that i'm not making
fun of you at all
i know some of you have had a year from
hell i understand we're here to help you
work through that
and be the third pig the next time in
the brick house when the big bad wolf
comes by we don't ever want you to be
there
again we want you to be in a reset mode
we're going to help you it's what we do
but your attitude is important
is reflected in this survey i think
i i would think so dave i think you're
right i had a setback
without a doubt but i'm up so
which way do i answer that question the
reason the way i answer that question is
based on my attitude not based on the
mathematical reality
ah this is the dave ramsey show